now out of China its former top
government scientist saying that the
Wuhan lab League theory for the origins
of covid should not be discounted saying
quote you can always suspect anything
that science don't rule out anything
Senator Rand Paul top Republican
Homeland Security committee Senator nice
to see you good morning and welcome back
uh here that this gentleman's name is Dr
George fugao he also said this
apparently in the same interview I think
their conclusion is that they're
following all the protocols they haven't
found any wrongdoing
so
what's it going to be
you know this is the head of the CDC in
China he's well known in international
circles and I think respected around the
world as being a truth teller I think
from the very beginning he was kept in
the dark and I think that now he's
trying to shed some light on this in
their kind of system is very difficult
and dangerous sometimes to tell the
truth and just indicating or intimating
that there that this could have come
from the lab is a big deal coming from a
government or an ex-government official
so I've spoken with the Chinese
government directly and asked them to be
more forthcoming not to blame them I've
really told them look we have these labs
in our country I don't want this to
happen in our country or anywhere in the
world again and I've asked them to be
more forthcoming I don't know if it'll
have any more response from the Chinese
government but I think it would be good
for the world if they were to come
forward and say look this was an
accident it was a terrible accident
we're doing everything to prevent it
happening again and then in the United
States we should also do more to try to
make sure that dangerous research what
you're saying is that you we everybody
should understand it uh for the for the
future but do you think this is as close
as we get
to a possible admission from the CCP
you know I hope we end up getting more
because you know I've spoken to former
high-ranking CDC officials in our
country who have told me that they
expect that there will be another leak
and that the next leak could be as much
as five to fifty percent of the world's
population could die in another pandemic
so we're crazy not to put more rules and
regulations on this type of research
I've been pushing this for three years
and to date I've not had a full
Committee hearing or get one Democrat to
agree to a full Committee hearing I've
been pushing Democrats to give me signed
records releases from the bite
Administration so far haven't gotten one
letter signed in three years by a
Democrat so it's amazing the cover-up
and you played a clip from fauci earlier
fauci was covering this up from day one
because he knew if it came to the lab
that ultimately culpability would attach
to his decisions to fund that very last
okay I don't know the clip that you're
talking about from earlier but this is
from June of 2022. yours fail to you
then
I said that I think the most likely
origin is a jumping of species I still
do think it is at the same time as I'm
keeping an open mind that it might be
elably okay I mean 11 months later is
that a fair statement keeping it open
well the thing is well no it's
absolutely not from day one from January
31st of 2020 he was conspiring with
fellow virologists to cover this up
because he knew he had been one of the
world's leading Advocates of gain of
function research for at least a decade
he's quoted as saying that gain of
function research is so important that
even if a pandemic breaks out it'll be
worth the knowledge he'd been an
advocate for a decade he was an advocate
and the Chief Architect of funding the
lab at Wuhan so he knew from the very
beginning if this leaked from the lab in
Wuhan that the guilt the culpability for
the pandemic would attach to his
horrific decision to fund this lab and
so no he's been trying to cover it up
from day one on it's only in the last
six months or so he started saying this
open mind thing but no he's been part of
an elaborate cover-up to make sure that
no one ever knew the truth but we're
going to get to the truth I promise you
when do we hear from him next about you
I think he'll be made to testify under
oath by the house if I had to predict
within the next couple of months they're
Gathering evidence there won't be any
chance because we don't have power in
the Senate to bring him in so he'll be
brought in and I suspect for one very
public uh interview under under oath and
we'll see if we get a truth out of him
but be prepared he was made to testify
in a Missouri Louisiana case and he said
I don't recall I think over 80 times
sir thank you for your time and we'll
see what comes of it on the house side
Rand Paul thank you I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis